[Music]
Teen Titans go is a hilarious and loved
show but it has suffered its fair share
of criticism much of the reason we've
come to love the series is because of
the characters wait until number one to
see which voices and characters we're
looking forward to for Teen Titans go to
the movies if this is your first time
checking out the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up wow you you sound like a
crazy person here's the voices behind
your favorite teen titans go characters
greg sites as Beast Boy Beast Boy is an
iconic character in his own right but if
you've been a fan of the animated series
for a while then you've definitely heard
his voice bring another legendary
character to life greg cipes
the actor who voices our beloved Beast
Boy in Teen Titans go is also
responsible for the voice of the one and
only Michael Angelo from Nickelodeon's
five seasons show Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles Sykes has done a great job as
the voice behind one of our favorite
characters little kids up to young
adults think of Beast Boy fondly and it
has a lot to do with the appeal cites is
added to the character for example it
was important to sites that Beast Boy
reflects a respectful attitude toward
women in the show he wanted to make sure
Teen Titans go would be a show that
girls enjoyed as much as boys would it
was sipes idea to call all the female
characters including Starfire and Raven
mama cites decision to do this was meant
to show that all women need to be
respected and as he divulges in an
interview with Mary Sue believes the
link to motherhood is a great way of
acknowledging and honoring women
original cast different vibes change can
be a challenge and it definitely was
when the original 2003 to 2006 animated
Teen Titans series was rebooted in 2012
two Teen Titans go the first series was
extremely popular and incorporated
action humor and DC comic iconic dark
themes seamlessly in a way that
entertained a diverse audience the
characters had a lot of depth and the
American made show incorporated a
compelling anime
style that was groundbreaking for the
animated series the show ended very
suddenly and the reboot was initially
met with a lot of criticism for being
over-the-top ridiculous
and radically different from the serious
show that preceded it however the show
made a pretty impressive recovery this
shift in tone had a lot to do with the
voice actors interpretation of the
comedic side of each characters with
whom they were already familiar from the
previous series for example in an indie
wire article Scott medval talks about
how his character Robin is funny because
he gets so frustrated when the others
don't listen to him meanwhile Tara
Strong gets to let out a lighter side of
Raven with her alter ego lady legasus
Greg Cipes admits that Beast Boy always
added comedic relief to the show so his
transition was very natural no way but
you just calm down
take some deep breaths Tara's strong as
Raven sometimes voice actors resemble
the characters they bring to life in
Tara Strong's case she looks nothing
like the angsty Raven her bright smile
and blond locks look a lot more like a
previous character she voiced bubbles
from Powerpuff Girls
in an interview with innovation in tech
today strong discusses her experience
with voice acting from video games
Batgirl and Fairly OddParents strong
admits that it can be hard to develop a
new voice for a new character in fact
the voice for Raven was a last-minute
suggestion and it ended up suiting the
character perfectly just like with
bubbles strong says that voicing a
character is a very personal and
emotional experience much of the
character's personality is developed by
the voice actor themselves and they live
within the actors mind strong says once
the show is over she really misses the
characters because it feels like losing
a little part of herself there's little
risk of strong having to go through a
sense of loss for Raven anytime soon
which is good news to us since Raven is
one of our favorites and wouldn't be the
same without strong voice voice actors
you didn't know we're on the show not
all of our favorite characters are main
characters the fact that there are no
small parts just small actors is
definitely true when it comes to some of
the guest celebrity appearances on the
show
you might have missed them but we're
sure you remember them fondly the swoon
worthy Aqualad makes a couple
appearances on Teen Titans go and gets
both Starfire and ravens attention the
voice of Aqualad is Wil Wheaton you
might know him as Wesley Crusher from
Star Trek or as a parody version of
himself on the Big Bang Theory what
about the time cyborg was undercover at
hive Academy and fell in love with
bumblebee her voice is t'keyah crystal
kima a disney channel comedian who you
might know as ravens mom on that So
Raven Kid Flash is voiced by will
Friedle from Boy Meets World some hearts
are even created just to allow a
celebrity's voice to be featured in the
show this was the case with Fall Out
Boy's Pete Wentz who appeared as himself
as did Cee Lo Green this was equally
exciting for once as it was for
directors Pete Michael and Erin Horvath
as they divulged in an interview with
the B comics culture Lauren Tom as gizmo
it goes for YouTube jinks wherever this
is it's over gizmo has been responsible
for leading a robot army he is one of
cyborgs most hated enemies and he's a
member of the high-five but that's not
all
gizmos voice comes from an actor with
tons of experience you've heard her
voice before behind some of your
favorite cartoon characters like Amy and
a Nez Wong from Futurama and king of the
hill in an interview with City Pages
Lauren Tom says she's really enjoyed her
career as a voice actor she also
discussed the opportunity for inclusion
in voice acting since there's much less
stereotyping she refers to herself as an
ethnic woman saying in live-action roles
it becomes a lot harder to be cast
because of the fact that she's a visible
minority in American pop culture this
hasn't stopped Tom from her success on
screen she starred as Ross's girlfriend
Julie on friends as well as her current
role on the Disney Channel show Andy
Matt Wow you you sound like a crazy
person Scott men Ville as Robin there's
no way we can talk about our favorite
teen titans go characters and not
mention Robin Scott men Vil's boys is an
inextricable part of Robins character
yet it's also the voice of several other
main characters in animated series
sometimes menville is simultaneously
responsible for different characters but
he still finds ways to make them
distinct
from one another in fact in an interview
with Collider menville even talks about
how each character can help inspire the
quirks of another character this is what
ended up happening with the voice of
stretch in Stretch Armstrong and the
flex fighters menville says that these
two characters have a lot of
similarities however it's the
contrasting characteristics that allow
him to create a different voice have you
ever noticed that Robins voice is a bit
more measured that something menville
has done on purpose to put across Robins
tendency to be skeptical of others as
well as stubborn a clearly distinct role
for men Ville is his voice work of Doc
Ock in Disney XD's Marvel's spider-man
menville
is responsible for the robbing we all
love 200th episode celebration when Teen
Titans go made its debut it was not
exactly starting from scratch the show's
premise changed a bit and the tone
changed completely from the typical
serious DC mood to a parody style comedy
what's more the characters voice actors
remain the same but with some
adjustments one big adjustment was the
fact that each show was a standalone
story involving the same characters this
worried a lot of the actors who had to
get used to the idea that they could die
in one episode and reappear alive and
well in the next episode the show had a
few growing pains but ended up being one
of Cartoon Network's most successful
animated series and this was well
celebrated during the 200th episode the
episode featured the creators Michael
jellinek and Aaron Horvath in animated
form forcing the Titans to write this
show themselves and learn how it's
created or disappear forever
this displayed the ownership the voice
actors have over our favorite characters
after all they're the ones who brought
the originality comedy and heart to the
show we just can't get enough of Carrie
Peyton as cyborg cyborgs voice actor
Carrie Peyton may be among the most
enthusiastic of the cast members to
promote the upcoming movie Teen Titans
go to the movies Dayton has come forward
in several interviews to advertise the
fact that he found the humor in the
movie so hilarious it caused him to wet
his pants several times though this may
seem a bit over the top it definitely
helps stir some curiosity among the fans
who are anxiously awaiting the movie an
article in Sydney Morning Herald
South Peyton's acting career Payton has
done several voiceover roles including
Rafiki for the lion guard on Disney
Junior
and of course cyborg he was then
approached to voice wasabi for big hero
six the series on Disney XD the Peyton's
acting range doesn't stop there
he got a lot of screen time in a major
role as king Ezequiel on walking dead
why do you seek an audience with the
king Payton even got a chance to work
with one of his voice actor role models
Mark Hamill who he didn't even recognize
at first hynden Walch as Starfire
Starfire is definitely a fierce warrior
and the Titans just wouldn't be the same
without her though the character has
been criticized because of her
impractical and revealing costumes she
nevertheless remains to be a fierce
superhero with a compelling attitude and
temper her voice has a lot to do with
this as hynden walch does a great job at
balancing Starfire's appeal without
compromising her strength and power in
fact Walsh has a knack at creating
amazing character voices for several
other animated series Walsh is behind
the voices of Princess Bubblegum from
adventure time Harley Quinn from the
Batman and Penny Sanchez from choc zone
the list of characters that Walsh is
responsible for is testament enough to
Walters ability to manipulate her voice
to fit a variety of emotions and
circumstances but we are just the
make-believe and they are the real just
as Starfire alone Walsh has the
capability to sound compassionate caring
and loving one minute and then vicious
determined and tough the next for this
reason it's pretty difficult to imagine
Starfire sounding any different but she
almost did Tara Strong was almost cast
to Starfire instead of wulc can you
imagine Starfire sounding like Raven or
Raven sounding any different new voices
for Teen Titans go to the movies with
all the hype around the upcoming Teen
Titans go to the movies we thought you'd
be interested in hearing some of the
most anticipated celebrities responsible
for some of the characters voices the
new trailer and the announcements about
the cast for the movie is lit we can
start by reassuring you that the
familiar voices behind your favorite
characters
oh man never let you fly my body again
will be the same in the movie as they
are in the show on top of that you'll
get to see some famous characters with
equally famous voices for example Halsey
will be voicing Wonder Woman and lil
yachty performs as one of Earth's Green
Lantern's curious about who's voicing
Superman by chance that would be none
other than Nicolas Cage who was admitted
to being a major fan of the iconic
American superhero but wait there's more
Will Arnett will be playing Deathstroke
while Kristen Bell voices Jade Wilson by
the way the trailer features a hilarious
moment I came out like way before he did
no I'm pretty sure you're Deadpool
making a distinction between Deathstroke
and Deadpool finally in case you were
concerned about the quality of comedy in
the movie James Corden has been cast as
balloon man so have any of these names
added to your excitement for the movie
let us know and that's all for the
voices behind your favorite Teen Titan
go characters if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]